para los sindicatos en Francia es el Día
de reunidos en un frente conjunto por
primera vez desde 2010 esperan que la
movilización de este jueves marque la
Pauta Empezando por la cgt de Philip
Martínez listos para esta primera
batalla con el gobierno
Estamos de acuerdo en que es una reforma
injusta
Nuestro objetivo es no a la prórroga de
la jubilación y a la prórroga de la
duración de las cotizaciones lo leyeron
en blanco y negro es el primer día pero
Habrá más
la línea roja para los sindicatos en la
ampliación de la edad legal de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años y el
alargamiento progresivo del periodo de
cotización harán falta 43 años para una
pensión completa La única solución a
ojos de la intersindical simplemente La
retirada de la Reforma una primera gran
prueba para el gobierno Que de momento
juega a la carta de la firmeza y no se
plantea ceder a la presión de la calle
aunque esta mañana el ministro de
trabajo aseguraba que escucha a los
trabajadores
en un movimiento social siempre hay
mensajes que oír mensajes que escuchar
la reforma que presentamos hoy la que
presentamos con la primera ministra hace
nueve días es una reforma que ha
cambiado respecto a la de hace cuatro
meses según un sondeo reciente más de
dos tercios de los franceses se oponen a
esta reforma de las pensiones los
sindicatos esperan un millón de personas
en las calles este jueves